I suppose the obvious analogy for Obama
would be Richard,
the second,
I don't buy it myself.
I think Obama a stronger president than
Richard.
The second was a king,
but a man who is perhaps politically
naive who is perhaps too cerebral for,
uh,
the world of sorted politics.
You could make a case for it.
I could see Obama as hamlet,
a man given to great cerebral
self-examination,
who finally realizes he has to act.
I don't see Obama's Richard the third,
the way a lot of people cast Richard
Nixon is Richard the third.
I don't seem Obama as Nick Beth,
although I think Macbeth,
when you go back to it,
is every ambitious person or at least
someone with the grains of ambition who
can be manipulated by an ambitious
person that you've ever known.
I'm,
the thing for me about Shakespeare is
that,
you know,
you see these people standing around the
water cooler.
I work with a dozen he yorkers.
Yeah.